well to talk more about this we're
joined by the chief executive of the cmi
anne frank and frank um
half of respondents uh think that it's
all going too fast
why is there an explanation well i think
the explanation
is um quite apparent um as we know
cases are uh surging they're uh
they're um fifty thousand and of course
britain now has
um the highest the third highest number
of cases in the world
um and equally we also know
uh that um many many many people are
being contacted i think it's up 46
week on week and asking to self-isolate
indeed
the secretary of state for health for
example has contacted covet and the
prime minister's been asked
to self-isolate so the disease is still
very prevalent amongst us and it is
creating a lot of anxiety for
many people including many managers
it's odd though isn't it because um
business leaders
are complaining on the one hand that uh
they're facing crisis because they can't
get everybody back to work
but half of them are now saying oh it's
all too quick
what what what should we really take
from that
well i think what we need to take from
this is that this pandemic
is um is complex there is not a one
one-size-fits-all solution
and what business leaders need to do is
assess their own situation carefully
and put in place measures that will
resonate for
their workforce their employees and
their customers
so for example if you are in a workplace
that requires people to be on site such
as
a restaurant or a hotel then it makes
absolute perfect sense that you should
be able to
ask people to take daily lateral flow
tests
and you know be able to come into work
if those tests are negative
if you're in a workplace such as
services that
can work very productively remotely well
then
actually you should um embrace the the
more
flexible working policies and we know
many managers want
to continue flexible working
post-pandemic
um how do you think business managers
are going to managers are going to feel
this morning when they see that um as
far as one can make out prime minister
and chancellor can get on with their
business
come what may um but frankly
doesn't look like they'll be able to get
their people in and
doing the jobs in the way they would
like them to
yeah and that's where it's very
important that things like this pilot
scheme to give people the option to test
take a lateral flow test and go into
work it's very important that that's
extended to
businesses that require onsite presence
i think that the other thing i would say
is that it's really important that
employers
engage with their employees and set a
framework
so that people understand uh what their
employers are going to be doing and give
the employees a say in that
um and and recognize there is not a
one-size-fits-all solution to
how we operate in covid um
just finally one of the most striking
things to me in these findings is that
uh two of the findings that suggest that
changes that
were forced by kobed may become
permanent three quarters say they'll
continue with covered measures
and two-thirds say they expect some or
all of the staff
to work remotely do you think that's the
new normal
well absolutely i think what's a a good
thing about
the pandemic is it's forced us to
re-evaluate our working practices and in
many cases modernize them
we know that 85 percent of managers
would like to continue with hybrid
working indeed 83
are working working hybrid at the moment
and that actually can be a more
productive and more enjoyable and a more
inclusive way of working
and so really we mustn't allow the
good changes in working practices to um
slip back to the way it was we have a
great opportunity to create a better
workplace culture
and frank thank you very much indeed for
your time this morning
thank you